in extension to volumes right we've
essentially looked at these two IDs
that's pretty much it right we know how
to do volumes that are just around a
corner access the body you dig a little
deeper if you say okay let's actually
think about what's going on think about
different kinds of slices think about a
different direction to cut up your
volume you get these different kinds of
shapes
okay now we're at that point where it's
okay well I understand these two when
you encounter a question the vast
majority of them in the HSC toss we sort
of say do this or that the buzz meter
however not all of them do and part of
the skill they're looking for us they're
looking to assess you is can you make a
choice between which one is the best one
right can you make a choice that will
render the algebra and you calculus and
all that kind of thing the simplest
right now I think what you'll find is
that basically since you've got two
choices
you're basically got two choices this is
a little bit like integration by parts
remember integration by parts can you
help me rehearse what is the formula for
you
- okay very good right so this is
integration by parts and of course if I
had some own some actual boundaries like
an A and a B then the difference would
be that's gonna be that's a 2b and good
you've got an actual definite integral
in here that can be evaluated okay now
really what sort of makes integration by
parts sort of move is which do you
choose for U and DV and you might recall
when we're doing integration okay
sometimes it's obvious that one should
definitely you know we should definitely
DB but sometimes it's not and so you
actually sometimes we would have chosen
one how to look at what your matrix of
different things were and said oh no I
want to go in this direction so that you
try the other one so you all find a
similar kind of thing with this you look
at a function and it might not be
obvious to you it might not be slap in
the face oh yes clearly do this by
slicing okay so you kind of have to see
what happens what kinds of integrals do
you form and therefore which direction
you're going so the place we should
start is by drawing a diagram in fact
we're going to go two diagrams multiple
sizes want the shelves so all you need
is your Sabattus you
now you'll notice I'm drawing this part
of the axis axis I should say because
number one and from not to plan two lots
of platitude
so that gives me just a little bit of
the y equals cos x Kurt but I'm rotating
around the y axis that's this way right
so therefore I'm going to get something
Selectric or about this axis so that's
why I've got so even components even
amounts of the negative and positive x
axis right so what is this shape look
like well when you go from naught to
plan to can someone describe to me what
like was because X is doing where's the
star starts up here at what and then it
just sort of comes down and that's it
that's the shape it's a single shape
isn't it okay let's just quickly shape
it in so we can demonstrate this is the
area involved and then you do the
rotation required which create this
opposing bit over here which luckily for
us is actually just what caused X
normally looks like and then you try and
add some things to this to make it look
a little more 3d because this is after
all a solid of revolution so like so
this is what I've got now let's first
think about slices I'm just going in the
order that we blurred them in so slices
cut up your volume in which direction
how do I come perpendicular to the axis
of rotation here is my axis of rotation
so if I would have picked out one of the
slices it might be based on an area like
that you see how this is perpendicular
to my Y axis we should I'm rotating
around okay so if I looked at that bit
and I said okay let's let's draw off to
the side what's an example of one of
these infinitesimally thin cylinders
then I guess it's going to look
something like this
okay what do you think this is pretty
straightforward in fact when you have a
look at this slices because what you get
is a YUM it's a complete slices not even
an annular slice it's just a regular old
cylindrical slice this is not
complicated at all right what's our
wrong thickness here that's nice
it's gonna be Delta Y cuz it's a
vertical distance and then the only
other thing you need to work out this
because you don't even have any inner
radius and an outer radius do you just
have a radius okay so what is this
radius here it's just the next one is it
because look it's horizontal really so
the x coordinate what is the x
coordinate
well remembering that this is y equals
cos x and noting the domain I mean which
is a nice Pleasant domain X is just
going to equal to cos inverse of Y okay
so therefore I should be able to say the
volume is equal to the limit as Delta Y
approaches zero where am i summing from
and what am i some which valleys what
kinds of variable my interested in their
Y values right and the way you can know
is because this isn't wise this is in
wise so I'm going from North up to one
yes and what's in here what am i adding
together
I'll just I'll write X square the not
substitute in the next line
and now I've got Delta Y do you agree
with that
so that thing there is my PI R squared H
there's my cylinder okay so on my next
line I'm going to write the integral so
I might as well take that pie out the
front just that constant R
roll and then what you getting in here
like I said this is not even an annulus
this is just a cylinder so even a two
unit student and they wouldn't be able
to solve it but they could at least
write down what this integral is it's
from north to one of I've already taken
that plan out so that leads me the
closing most of X square that's right
why rather why right with respect to one
okay yeah please no no now I should
point up this sum this integral is not
in soluble it can be done and I will
show you very very briefly in the end I
won't actually work it out for you but I
will show you what happens if you choose
to go down this path but I think we all
agree we don't want to turn this part
okay so this is like when you've done
your integration by parts and you look
at U DV and you're like oh this thing's
gonna be a pain so you sort of steer
away from okay I asked you don't know if
you've got it yet I asked you to draw
two diagrams so let's do another one
let's do another one same area same axis
of rotation but this time we're going to
slice it up differently